yeah so those I wanted to talk about a
paper here it is it's called the
symmetry and simplicity of the laws of
physics and the Higgs boson which isn't
a particularly catchy title well well
well the scene is done and maldacena is
a big shot right I'd have seen it
generally doesn't do this sort of thing
which is you know talking about almost
like an outreach paper he's describing
the you know the fundamental laws of
physics as in gauge symmetry as
spontaneous symmetry breaking the way
the Higgs works and he's done it using
an analogy of economics so what what's
is a economic analogy then for to
describe all this to understand really
fundamental physics the standard model
just from economics that's always been
little in economics is it's a it's
really simple what what Melda saying it
starts with he starts by trying to
explain gauge symmetry and he talks
about three bunch of country so I want
you to imagine three countries so one
can be the UK may be the US Brady you
want me to make the other one Australia
don't you but I'm not going to I'm going
to make it Spain because I'm half
Spanish okay sir you've done excellent
excellent maps there yes they are
they're sort of nicely placed actually
aren't they hat like that cut it V
orientated right yeah anyway but and in
so you've got these three countries and
I want you to imagine bridges between
the countries and an each bridge there
is a bank now each bank can you know set
an exchange rate between the current
Jesus you cross that you know cross
between the two countries are you gonna
draw a little bags you can draw let's
draw a little back yeah
okay let's try Leon Bank put Bank on it
and do have to draw three banks everyone
yeah let's go
I know birds move up a bank on this one
because it's going to Spain in it this
one called Bank as well right okay so
this these bankers banks on every bridge
you can change money at these banks now
the banks set the exchange rate they
don't make money then they're not in it
to make money so the exchange rate works
the same both ways so for example and on
the at the UK US border you've got maybe
one pound to say let's say three dollars
quite a generous exchanger there's no
charge any commission either okay so and
as just to emphasize if you if you went
with a pound that way you'd get three
dollars and you came
three dollars this way you get a pound
back there's no money making by the
banks here here you know maybe one pound
to two euros okay and here we've got say
let's say a dollar to a euro so just for
simplicity let's just start with this
note now you can ask yourself can I make
money so you think of a speculator kind
of speculator make money and you can
either immediately see that you can
right just by going around going around
the countries in the right order so for
example you start with two euros here in
Spain you go to England it turns into a
pound you then go to America it turns
into three dollars and then you come
back to Spain again and it's now three
euros so you made a euro okay so you can
see so so what you're measures there are
speculators and then they go round and
in this case they want to go round in
that direction so this in a way what
whatever maldacena says this is like
says the speculators are like electrons
or charged particles and they're going
round in this sort of the
electromagnetic field which is set up by
the banks through their exchange rates
okay so the exchange rates set up the
electromagnetic field and the electron
or the speculators move around in it
this explains this process and of course
if I change the exchange rates it
changes how the electric D of the
speculators will move okay so they might
go in a different direction they may not
move at all if I made it so that so that
all the exchange rates will one-to-one
okay there's going to be no movement as
speculators so this is sort of explains
it they know electrodynamics that the
nice thing about it as well is the malla
Center argues that if the banks don't
want to run our money okay if I had this
setup forever eventually speculators
would go round and round and round and
round and eventually the banks would run
out of money so he says the banks don't
want to do that so what they do is they
can change their exchange rates
certainly to protect themselves from
this and if you work out this actual the
equations that govern that it turns out
that they're the same as Maxwell's
equations that describe electromagnetism
it's kind of beautiful right so it's you
really do have electromagnetism going on
here speculators you said our electron
yeah what are the banks the banks are
like the gauge field
they'd have dead a sort of
electromagnetic field if you like in
this scenario I do not be
electromagnetic field it can be
associated with the with the air weak
force for example and what's an example
of the transaction where electrons are
making money in nature well that's where
they're interacting with the
electromagnetic field so that would be
precisely that so they're moving in the
electromagnetic field because
essentially in this scenario it's like
moving through the banks you know making
money and along the way in the analogy
what is money in the analogy what are
now that's a good that's good we are
going to come to that so money in a way
is a little bit like energy here at
least the money that you gain is a
little bit like energy that's what my
listener argues so that's kind of so in
a sense this brings us to we'll come to
at that important point in a moment
one more question in the analogy what
our country's points in space that's
important as well okay so each point of
space is a contouring here okay so
you're literally moving around space
here so but what's an important aspect
of this is that any given country is
free to change its currency okay so for
example the guys in America could change
make you have the value of the dollar if
they wanted to and all that would mean
is the banks would just change what they
meant by a dollar in their exchange rate
it wouldn't change how the speculators
moved and how they could make money and
it's the same that's gauge symmetry and
of in physics the other important aspect
of this scenario is that let's suppose
they are all one to one exchange rates
okay so now we know that we're calling
this like the vacuum configuration okay
because the electrons don't move in this
because the speculators don't move
there's no risk of the fields don't make
anything happen
the banks aren't making anything happen
there's no movement of the of the
speculators here but there is an
interesting aspect of this which is
which is important let's suppose that
all the exchange rates in the moment and
our one to one okay so that electrons
don't want to move around can I kind of
but what can i maintain that's it
situation by changing the exchange rates
in one of the monks so let's suppose
this guy here changes one dollar to two
euros connect can I maintain the
scenario of say no movement of
speculators well you can because this
bag can respond and change it the value
of its euro okay so if you double the
amount you exchange rate if you are as
here in just double it here it's still
at a no movement situation you can't
make money in this scenario and that's
an important distinction okay that's so
what's that saying is it cost no not it
doesn't cost the bank's anything to
change the exchange rate okay it's
costing any magic it costing no energy
to sort of to the field here and this is
this is analogous to a massless particle
so the gauge fields are behaving like
massless particles it cost them no
energy to change the exchange rates okay
now what happens when you throw the
Higgs in now the Higgs doesn't doesn't
read out we don't use the Higgs to it to
give mass to the to the particles in the
electromagnetic field it's it's done
with it with the weak force and na you
know this sort of W and Z bosons those
kinds of things
but you can still think about this kind
of scenario and it so what what is the
Higgs well the Higgs is gold so all
exchange rates are let's say they're all
one to one no money can be made by
speculators in this scenario but now I
add some gold to the game let's suppose
there's some the price of gold in the UK
I have no idea of this is a sensible
price one kilogram is 1 million pound ok
now in the u.s. one kilogram of gold is
worth two million dollars so all
exchange rates are one sort and can you
make money now previously you couldn't
until I introduced the gold you couldn't
make money now you can make money it's
very easy to see how to make money in
this snow you just start off you buy
some gold in England with your million
pounds you've got a million pounds on
you Brady okay so you buy some gardening
or your million pound you then go to
America you turn that into you go and
sell your gold in America for two
million dollars and then you go back to
England and it turns into two million
pounds so you made a million quid okay
so you can see that suddenly the
situation has changed
okay so suddenly this gold has changed
the picture there's another thing that
you see Rose is that in a sense the
what's important here is the price of
God you could redefine the currency in
any given country so that the price of
gold is always 1 million okay
let's suppose we do that okay so we as
price of gold is always a million so now
we're going to redefine at the dollar so
a new dollar okay instead of being the
new dollar it's going to be instead of
being too many dollars for a kilogram of
gold might have put a pound sign in
front of that instead of eight - really
dollars for a kilogram it's going to be
instead it's going to be 1 million new
dollars okay I put n in front of me okay
okay and it's still a million pounds but
now the banks have to respond to that
okay so they have to have the number of
dollars in their exchange rates so it's
now one to two so we just draw at the
side here probably using ads so this is
now 1/2 1/2 1/2 to 1 and 1 to 1 okay in
response to that the fact that the price
each country's changed its currency to
the price of God is always a million so
now you can see you can see now you can
see that you can make money through the
exchange rate but suppose you now have a
scenario where all exchange rates were
one to one the price of gold is one
everywhere 1 million everywhere all
exchange rates are one to one now that's
a scenario where you can't make money
price of God's fixed everywhere as 1
million the exchange rates are all one
to one can't make money in that scenario
now before and we said that a bank could
change this exchange rate okay and all
the banks could respond and you could
still have a scenario where you can't
make money so there's no cost in no cost
of the banks however now then the gold
comes into play if one bank wants to
change this exchange rate another bank
can't respond to that in such a way as
to guarantee there's no money making
because you could always pass between
those two countries for which the first
Bank changes exchange rate and then you
can make money carrying gold carrying
gold in your pocket exactly so this is
now so what
so this is fundamentally different to
what's happened it's now become
impossible for the banks to change their
exchange rates and maintain the status
quo of no money making it's cost them
energy what this means is is the this is
analogous to the gauge field having
gained mass having gained energy okay it
costs them it costs them to it to change
the exchange it now cost them okay
just as it costs you to move a massive
particle if you like it's kind of
analogous to that so this is this is the
standard model in action this is exactly
how it works so that adding the gold
breaks you know essentially gives mass
to these two these two this gauge field
it's essentially what it's doing is
giving mass to the max it's making it
harder for the banks so they can't just
play around with their exchange rates
now it's such a way that they can
guarantee that the speculators don't
make money that can't happen now one one
guy changes the exchange rate then
that's it you can make money there is
one final final twist of it is where's
where's the Higgs particle in this story
okay so the Higgs particle to see the
Higgs particle of course there's nothing
physical in a sense about the precise
price of gold in any given country
because I could always redefine my
currency okay so it's I could always
make it 1-1 it can be two million
dollars that I can change that to 1
million new dollars okay
that's no big deal however what you can
introduce this is silver into the game
now and now there is something physical
which is the difference between the
price of gold and silver in a given
country something like that would be the
Higgs particle what do I take from this
about the nature of nature look it
almost seems like Messi is bad for
nature like like almost like nature
wishes mass didn't exist because it
ruins this perfect setup they had that's
exactly I think that's completely right
Brady the matter requires the
introduction of mass requires that you
know breaking a symmetry okay you're
breaking that symmetry this is
spontaneous symmetry breaking against
what we call it and that's what the
Higgs does it wants you to spot the
symptoms as symmetry which is
spontaneously broken to give mass to the
air to the gauge bosons and and you see
it here in the bank analogy you add gold
to the game and suddenly the banks don't
have this symmetry anymore that they can
just play around
right and it doesn't cost them anything
so is it almost like like mass us you
and me is sort of this aberration or
this thing that this wart on the
backside of nature if you like yeah yeah
yeah I mean one thing that we know about
about nature is that it you know the
symmetries are broken you know and you
know for example a you know
supersymmetry that we talked about it
looking for at the LHC that would be
great for doing solving some problems
like the like say the cosmological
constant problem but we can't use it
because it's broken in nature so it's no
good to us okay so yeah actually Polly
this way life would be easier for
physicists if we could solve all of all
lots of very difficult problems if we
had loads of symmetry and we could just
you know we could say oh this this value
with this thing is zero because it's
because of symmetry so Alex would be
easier if physicists didn't physically
exist yeah the problem is that
physicists wouldn't exist if these
symmetries of it were there but they
could solve the problems I sent into the
garden and drank tea under the shade of
some apple trees so he's so he's kind of
recalling an anecdote here of him just
hanging out with Isaac Newton and what
they're talking about right and then
you--some starts remembering the apple
tree story amidst other discourse he
told me he was just in the same
situation as when formerly the notion of
gravitation came into his mind